в Україні пройдуть не моя живіт жахливо
заявив і просто рівня 2 нових партій
одну на базі дим альянсу летить Сергій
лещенко то мустафа наймо другові до школи
саакашвілі ви буду voy a trifle чумак
ascot сакварелідзе
йти йти не задував і не дворічна
реальністю парламенту добре я
партія на весну ються картель
організації кисляком картерних газів на
сьогоднішній день тут немає вода україна
майдан не породи при 1000
жопні та політично бренди окислилися з
фактично е ну
перетасував і стеша був раніше ним бо
чим він і не вистачає а то щоб razon
з брендом та новим зради тягни підходу
долар взуття 2 політичний проект та
доповідати одну і ту ж мету повний
пара за монтажі та влади
і абсолютно не прийняти про корупцію
глибина по гаму я ще буду бік
таких партій shady кілька
і ми просто всі партії взяв її витіснила
всебічну офісної партії ланки прям
на вигляд очей
цьому ми створимо всю силу котрий ще
різні лапах ліфт блохи цінність
антикорупція європейської шивани став і
думі ну і чого доведеться
путін так і схожі політичний вектор u
може грати з новими партії ми злі жар
а дживан і борід і ми всі за один
електорат патріотично заснованих алленів
задоволений екзаменам і вкрай не вибір
тел
досить сотки в цінуєш а нового
середнього класу та нового покоління
ніяких ока створа не нових партій і
щоб не будучи конкурувати між
бою боюся програють сил і акція в
полон і на українську політичну
ландшафт стани відома не раніше осені
найтуди партійні нового твій план
затишок та копальні format of my status